und jetzt das heute journal
guten abend bundeskanzler scholz und dem
manuellen marken haben erneut wladimir
putin telefoniert und nach dem was
danach verlautbart wurde verlief das
gespräch ein bekannter spiel aufstellung
putin warnte vor weiteren
waffenlieferungen und getreideexporte
aus der ukraine werde er nur ermöglichen
wenn die sanktionen gegen russland
gelockert werden brot für die welt als
faustpfand sozusagen
derweil den russischen truppen im
donbass offenbar die einnahme einer
weiteren stadt gelungen ist dominique
löschmeister gibt einen überblick über
das heutige kriegsgeschehen es sind
bilder der zerstörung satelliten
aufnahmen des us-unternehmens mixa
zeigen die kriegsfolgen in der ost
ukraine
massive russische angriffe bringen die
ukrainischen verteidiger im donbass in
bedrängnis der ukrainische präsident
zielinsky bezeichnete die lage als sehr
schwierig sie setzen im dom bass ein
maximum an artillerie und reserven 1 es
gibt raketen und luftangriffe alles es
droht die einkesselung in den steppen c
f zero donetsk und lissy das klima im
norden ist bereits gefallen ebenso port
passenden süden nur bach mut wird noch
gehalten
es geht nun darum zivilisten aus der
region heraus zu bringen die frontlinie
nur wenige kilometer entfernt
wir fahren zur verwandtschaft aber wir
werden zurückkommen nachdem das alles
hier vorbei ist und sich wieder beruhigt
hat
der ukrainische provinz gouverneur
spricht bereits von einem taktischen
rückzug
noch haben wir genug kraft und
ressourcen um uns zu verteidigen
trotzdem ist es möglich dass der befehl
kommt und zurückzuziehen damit wir nicht
umzingelt werden
wie diese bilder des ukrainischen
verteidigungsministeriums beweisen
sollen setzt russland inzwischen auch
thermo bayerische waffen ein diese
gerechten vakuum bomben entfachen einen
gewaltigen feuersturm unabhängig
überprüfen lässt sich das nicht die
ukrainischen verteidiger sie geraten in
der ost ukraine immer mehr unter druck
das regime von naddel hatte mir putin
ist ja nicht das einzige zu sehen sich
die demokratie in dieser welt verhalten
müssen auch die volksrepublik china ist
ein staat von dem man sich auf die ein
oder andere weise wirtschaftlich
abhängig gemacht hat und sich das mit
wandel durch handel schönredet während
offensichtlich ist wie die diktatoren in
peking mit ihren kritikern umgehen ihr
volk überwachen oder die
freiheitsbestrebungen in hongkong
zerschlugen nun belegen auch noch die
umfänglichen dokumente der bank papers
wie uiguren in umerziehungslager
interniert werden folterungen inklusive
da durfte man gespannt sein was die
menschenrechtskommissarin der vereinten
nationen dazu sagt zum abschluss ihrer
china-reise ulf röller hat das
beobachtet
als junge frau hat michelle bachelet
selbst folter erlebt ihre familie vielen
ungnade während der pinochet diktatur in
chile sie und ihr vater wurden
eingesperrt nun ist sie die
menschenrechtskommissarin der un und in
china unterwegs man hätte sie gerne zu
ihrer vergangenheit befragt aber die
chinesen schirmten sie ab bahceli ließ
sich ein buch zu menschenrechten
schenken dass präsident selbst
geschrieben hat sie ist nicht gekommen
um aufzuklären
dieser besuch ist keine untersuchung
sagt sie
angesichts der neuen dokumente klingt
der satz wie ein fahrrad sie belegen
dass brutale lagersystem die
schockierenden fotos und die
umfangreichen dateien zeigen das ganze
grauen im namen der
terrorismusbekämpfung wird die
muslimische minderheit in china
unterdrückt die beschlagnahmten beweise
für radikale gesinnung wirken wie hohen
das alles erwähnt branche lee nicht nur
sehr vorsichtig übt sie kritik
ich ermutige china seine
terrorismusbekämpfung zu überprüfen um
sicherzustellen dass sie den
menschenrechts standards entsprechen
china hat den besuch von michelle
bachelet
populistisch ausgeschlachtet im
staatsfernsehen wird gezeigt wie sie
andächtig den chinesischen präsidenten
ski lauscht während der sein land für
die gute menschenrechtspolitik lobt
barschels schweigen für die mitglieder
des weltkongresses der uiguren
unerträglich viele von ihnen haben
familienangehörigen lagern sie fühlen
sich verraten
werden frauen stabilisiert werden frauen
in internierungslager im gefängnis sind
gefoltert vergewaltigt und wieso jemand
dem besucht und sagt gar nichts sie
müsste meiner meinung nach sofort
zurücktreten
[Musik]
diktaturen leben vom wegschauen das hat
michelle bachelet sehr früh erfahren
heute hätte sie diesen opfern eine
stimme geben können aber sie schwieg
und jetzt die nachrichten von heinz wolf
bundessozialminister heil schlägt
zusätzliche finanzielle entlastungen ab
dem kommenden jahr vor für menschen mit
geringen und mittleren einkommen sowie
hartz 4 empfänger ein sogenanntes klima
geld soll es geben für alleinstehende
mit einem monatsbrutto verdienst unter
4000 euro und für verheiratete mit
weniger als 8000 euro zusammen
angesichts einer möglichen neuen corona
welle im herbst hat sich rwe chef wieder
für vorkehrungen ausgesprochen und für
gesetzliche rahmenbedingungen zur
anwendung von maßnahmen die derzeit
geltende fassung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes läuft bis zum
23 september und in der
regierungskoalition gibt es aktuell eine
diskussion über die korona
schutzvorgaben für den herbst
im handel gilt ab heute eine neue
verordnung zur angabe von preisen ziel
ist unter anderem den verbraucherinnen
und verbrauchern die übersicht zu
erleichtern etwa durch grundpreis
informationen pro kilogramm oder liter
und zusätzliche angaben bei
preisermäßigungen
die fußballerinnen des vfl wolfsburg
haben das dfb pokalfinale gewonnen gegen
turbine potsdam mit vier zu null und
jetzt die lottozahlen dieses samstags
sie lauten wie immer ohne gewähr 1 14 20
36 superzahl 1 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf de und im
zdf text auf seite 5 56
und die wetteraussichten morgen ist der
himmel wechselnd bewölkt mit schauern
und einzelnen gewittern
der wind weht mäßig aus nord bis
nordwest mit elf bis 18 grad ist es
recht kühl am montag gibt es die meisten
schauer und gewitter im norden und im
osten ab dienstag vor allem im süden
allmählich wird es wärmer am mittwoch 20
bis 26 grad
heute abend gehen die filmfestspiele in
cannes zu ende mit der verleihung der
goldenen palme für den besten film und
die ging in diesem jahr an den schweden
haben ist für seine haben schwarze high
society satire trial of sadness den film
haben wir ihnen diese woche hier im
heute-journal auch vorgestellt ihres
besteht darin mit
es war diesmal ein jubiläumsjahr an der
côte d'azur die 75 festspiele sabine
schulz zieht für uns bilanz wie wahr
dieser festival jahrgang
es war ein festival der krassen
gegensätze
es gab berührende filme wie die
migrationsgeschichte der brüder dardenne
ganz nah an den menschen und
[Musik]
schockierende filme
wie die düstere zukunftsvision von david
cronenberg
tom cruise machte werbung für top gun 2
maverick und ließ spektakulär echtes
darf weiter über den himmel von cannes
donnern
die filme wache der ukraine angereist
aus dem realen krieg fanden das gar
nicht lustig
sie protestierten mit allen mitteln
gegen vergewaltigungen der russischen
armee gegen den krieg an sich und gegen
die teilnahme eines russischen films im
wettbewerb die widersprüche dieser welt
in cannes lagen sie ganz dicht
beieinander
die verzweiflung über putins krieg neben
dem glamour und sexappeal perfekt
gestylt der models der star kult neben
dem versuch die filmkunst und die
zukunft des kinos zu retten zum 75
jubiläum eine neu gestaltete goldene
palme aus dem hause chopard verziert mit
100 diamanten doch die bilder vor den
kinosälen waren mitunter stärker als die
geschichten auf der leinwand einer der
ganz großen jahrgänge bei dieser kann
ausgabe leider nicht
das war es auch schon von uns die
nächste heute express gibt es gegen 0.30
auf wiedersehen wieder sind
[Musik]